Donc nous sommes devant la conclusion de la lettre de Paul au Galate, cette lettre qui est appelée la lettre de la liberté, donc l'insistance primaire de l'apôtre Paul,
c'est que personne dans l'environnement chrétien, personne qui a déjà expérimenté de façon authentique la conversion, ne soit dérobé de cette liberté filiale avec Dieu.
La grande thèse de l'apôtre Paul devant les dangers des Galates, c'est que ceux qui sont en Jésus-Christ par la foi, ceux qui ont compris l'évangile de Jésus-Christ par la foi,
même s'ils n'avaient pas un arrière-plan religieux juif, en ayant contemplé Jésus dans sa manière parfaite de vivre,
et la manière dont Christ a été crucifié à la croix, même si on n'a pas un arrière-plan religieux juif,
on est devant la manière la plus explicite dont on pourrait être exposé à la loi des dieux,
à toutes les exigences des dieux en termes de vivre, de vie.
Donc toute la loi visait à nous rappeler qu'on a été créé à l'image des dieux à l'origine,
qu'on devrait vivre une vie à l'image des dieux,
une vie d'amour, une vie parfaite, une vie pour les biens de soi, des autres,
et pour la gloire des dieux surtout.
Et donc même si, dans notre condition charnelle,
la loi des dieux révélée dans l'Ancien Testament
nous rappelle, confirme les restes de notre conscience
et donne beaucoup de détails par rapport aux saintes exigences des dieux,
par rapport à notre manière de vivre,
elle ne pourra jamais être comparée à cette révélation concrète
d'un dieu qui vit entre nous,
dieu incarné, Jésus-Christ.
Ce qui fait que même les païens dans la Galatie
n'avaient pas besoin forcément de connaître l'Ancien Testament
ou la loi mosaïque.
C'était suffisant pour eux de contempler la manière dont Christ a vécu
et le fait qu'il était mort de cette manière si tragique
pour démontrer ce qu'on méritait à l'enfer.
Et en contemplant Jésus-Christ crucifié,
ils avaient compris l'ensemble de l'Évangile.
Ils n'étaient même plus en mesure de comprendre la loi mosaïque et l'Ancien Testament
avec Christ comme clé d'interprétation.
Ils avaient pu réjouir de toute cette promesse pleine
du déversement même du Saint-Esprit
qui était si tant attendu
depuis toute l'Ancienne Alliance et l'Ancien Testament.
Donc il n'y avait rien qui manquait dans la relation légitime et authentique des Galates,
dans la réjouissance d'une relation libre avec Dieu,
non seulement libre
de ces systèmes lourds de l'administration mosaïque,
les rituels
fatigants qu'avaient
les Juifs,
mais libres dans le sens où ils étaient véritablement affranchis de leurs désirs charnels
et qu'ils progressaient dans une conformité évidente
avec la sainteté du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Ils étaient greffés véritablement par les Saint-Esprits à Jésus-Christ
et voilà pourquoi la vie du Christ s'est manifestée en eux.
C'est-à-dire,
ils vivaient comme des vrais enfants des dieux,
comme Christ.
Et d'une manière beaucoup plus claire et criante
que tous les efforts que les épocrites religieux pharisaïques
ou les judaïsants
pourraient démontrer dans l'apparence.
Peut-être qu'ils ne s'habillaient pas
d'une manière si resserrée
que les judaïsants,
mais ils vivaient une vie beaucoup plus sainte qu'il a l'heure.
Et donc, ce que l'apôtre Paul vise en Galaxe,
c'est de communiquer de manière claire
que Christ et la Nouvelle Alliance
est l'accomplissement de tous les types et ombres d'Ancien Testament,
que tous ces types et ombres sont devenus obsolètes
et que c'était de marcher radicalement en arrière,
de revenir
à cette soumission à la circoncision
et à un système légaliste
pour croire qu'ils pouvaient
atteindre
un niveau plus privilégié,
plus authentique,
pour avancer en sainteté
et pour se considérer
enfants des premiers rangs.
Car les juifs ethniques
se considéraient comme ça.
Donc voilà la thèse principale d'apôtre Paul,
c'est
les mêmes évangiles
qui nous justifient devant Dieu
de manière légale,
c'est-à-dire
Dieu nous déclare juste sur la base
des mérites du Christ.
Il a vécu la vie parfaite à notre place,
il est mort à la croix
pour souffrir la punition qu'on méritait.
Donc, une fois qu'on place sincèrement
notre foi en Jésus-Christ,
une fois qu'on a cette rencontre expérimentale
est réelle en Jésus-Christ,
avec Christ,
Dieu nous considère désormais,
désormais pour toujours,
comme en ayant à temps
la barre pleine des perfections,
des saintetés
et des punitions qu'on méritait.
Donc la dette,
elle est complètement payée, effacée.
Et la grande question,
la deuxième grande question,
c'est que les judaïsants
pourraient même être d'accord
dans la théorie avec ça,
mais il disait,
mais une fois que vous êtes en Christ,
il faut que vous reveniez
aux habitudes
des vrais enfants ethniques
nationaux des dieux,
les systèmes religieux d'Israël.
Pour ne pas perdre votre salut,
pour être considéré
comme un vrai chrétien,
pour progresser en sainteté,
vous avez besoin
d'être constamment
sous les menaces
névrotiques
de cette relation avec Dieu
qui semble plus la relation
d'un esclave
qui a toujours peur
d'être viré,
d'être chassé,
de ne pas être traité
comme un enfant
au lieu
de considérer
que de manière effective,
vous-même, Galate,
vous avez pu constater
que depuis votre conversion,
vous marchez volontairement,
avec désir,
vous progressez
en sainteté.
c'était ça,
les dangers
des personnes
qui se sont infiltrées
à l'église des Galates
qui,
de manière exprès,
faisaient évidente
leur externalité religieuse
et qui cherchaient
à convaincre les Galates
qu'ils devraient
se faire circoncir.
qui voulaient rendre
ces personnes
esclaves.
Et donc,
en arrivant
à cette conclusion,
Paul,
il revient
aux questions
principales de la lettre.
Les dangers
d'un posteur
entre vous,
l'importance
de la compréhension
du vrai évangile
dont la justification
comprend
non seulement
cette déclaration légale
où Dieu dit
aux vrais chrétiens
désormais,
il n'y a plus
de condamnation
pour toi,
mais aussi,
la justification
comprend
cette puissance
qui nous affranchit
non seulement
de la coupabilité
du péché,
mais de la pollution
ou de la puissance
du péché.
Et donc,
les vrais chrétiens,
c'est celui
qui,
à partir du moment
où il a été converti,
il peut voir clairement
un désir prédominant
pour la sanctification
plutôt
qu'il a force
des désirs charnels
et qu'il peut voir
ses progrès
en sainteté
dans sa vie.
Beaucoup plus efficace
que toutes les menaces
que la loi
ne pourrait
jeter sur nous.
Il n'a pas
si tant peur
de finir à l'enfer
avec la peur
de ses souffrances.
Juste l'idée
dans sa tête
de pouvoir
attrister
les Saint-Esprit
et se moquer
de la croix
du Christ
est suffisant
pour qu'il soit
infiniment plus motivé
à honorer
son père
que d'écrandre
les juges
de l'univers.
Et donc,
pour finir la lettre,
Paul,
il revient
à la considération
directe
de ses imposteurs
au sein de l'Église.
il veut
non seulement
équiper
l'Église
à identifier
et discriminer
entre
un imposteur
et un vrai chrétien,
un faux prophète
ou un faux apôtre
ou un faux ministre
et un vrai apôtre,
un vrai ministre,
mais il vise
aussi
l'Église
à identifier
la réalité
de l'Évangile
dans sa conception
théologique
et dans sa conception
pratique,
la transformation
des vies,
la constance
les fruits
de l'esprit
manifesté.
Mais il vise
aussi
à responsabiliser
l'Église
car même si
Paul reconnaît
tout le long
de la lettre
qu'il y a
une partie
des victimes
chez les Galates,
ils ne sont pas
ou ils ne sont jamais
totalement victimes
de l'exploitation
des judaïsants.
Et donc,
cette responsabilisation
est importante
car même si Paul
est en train
de parler
indirectement
des judaïsants,
il est en train
de diriger
cette exhortation
à l'Église
et c'est donc
de se responsabiliser
et d'évaluer
à quel point
ou de quelle manière
ma chair
est en train
de vouloir
se laisser tromper,
se laisser influencer
jusqu'où
je me suis permis
d'aller
sous l'influence
de ces judaïsants.
Et donc,
cette exhortation
d'Église
de Paul
finale
pour conclure
la lettre,
comme je vous ai dit,
elle sonne
plutôt comme
un ultimatum.
Il ne parle pas
des communions
futures avec
Galate,
il ne parle pas
des projets
missionnaires,
il ne parle pas
des reconnaissances
avec un Dieu
qu'il pourrait avoir
comme pour toutes
les autres lettres
de Paul
dans le Nouveau Testament.
C'est comme si
Paul avait écrit
cette lettre
en disant
voici l'ultimatum
du Dieu
qui ne peut pas
être moqué.
Non seulement
les judaïsants
sont en train
de se moquer
des dieux
au milieu de vous
et vous,
vous êtes en train
aussi de vous moquer
des dieux
en donnant
de l'espace
à eux.
Et donc,
c'est comme si
Paul,
qui nous enseigne
beaucoup sur
les ailes des dieux
sur l'Église,
c'est comme si
Paul était en train
de dire
maintenant,
l'ultimatum
a été fait
et la seule chose
qui vous attend
d'ici vers l'avant,
c'est comme
s'il disait
la fin
de la limite
de la patience
des dieux
envers vous.
soit Dieu
manifestera
son aile
par son
fort jugement,
soit vous
allez saisir
l'occasion
à la vraie
répentance.
Et donc,
la vérité centrale
pour nous,
c'est que les tests
ultimes
de la réalité
d'une nouvelle création
ou d'une vie
qui s'églorifie
exclusivement
dans la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ,
pardon,
c'est que les tests
ultimes
de la réalité
d'une nouvelle création
est une vie
qui s'églorifie
exclusivement
dans la croix
du Seigneur
Jésus Christ.
Donc,
voici
ce que nous
retrouvons
de manière claire
dans ces passages
où,
au verset
14,
nous trouvons
ce qui va faire
la distinction
principale
entre les imposteurs
et les vrais chrétiens.
« Loin des mois
la pensée
de me glorifier
d'autres choses
qu'à la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ,
par qui les mondes
est crucifié pour moi
comme je suis aussi
pour les mondes.
Car ce n'est rien
que d'être circoncis
ou en circoncis,
c'est qu'il y a quelque chose,
c'est d'être
une nouvelle créature. »
Donc,
soit nous sommes
des nouvelles créatures
devant des nouvelles créatures,
soit nous sommes
devant des personnes
qui ont appris
très bien
à s'entraîner
dans un environnement
religieux
pour dire les choses
en conformité
avec la théorie
biblique,
théologique,
se comporter
de manière similaire
à la manière
dont il voit
les vrais chrétiens
se comporter
et même
dissimuler
des affections
similaires
à ce qui
semble être
convenable
à certaines occasions.
Et donc,
la réalité,
à la fin des comptes,
c'est que
dans les longs termes
de leur vie,
plus tôt ou plus tard,
Dieu dévoilera
et ça sera évident.
et donc,
Paul est en train
de présenter
les recours
qu'on puisse avoir,
les évidences
pour discerner
entre les imposteurs
et les vrais croyants
pour que nous puissions
nous retrouver
et nous responsabiliser
devant ces cas.
Donc,
quelles sont les preuves,
la question clé pour nous,
quelles sont les preuves
d'une vie
qui s'églorifie
exclusivement à Jésus-Christ
par opposition
à l'hypocrisie religieuse.
Donc là,
Paul,
il va donner
ses comparaisons
dans la conclusion
de sa lettre
et nous avons déjà considéré
un premier aspect
et c'est notamment
la première réponse
qu'on a considérée
les dimanches derniers.
Une vie
qui s'églorifie
réellement
dans la croix
manifeste
une affection authentique
pour Christ,
son évangile
et pour son peuple
plutôt
qu'un faux soin
intéressé.
Donc,
Paul,
au verset 11,
il dit
« Voyez avec
quelle grande lettre
je vous ai écrit
de ma proprement. »
Donc ça,
on a bien considéré,
je vous encourage
à revenir après
sur les messages
enregistrés,
mais Paul,
il est en train
de démontrer
de manière très claire
et avec beaucoup
de contraste
avec la manipulation
des pharisiens,
la constance
et la bonne proportion
de ses affections
et l'intensité
avec beaucoup
de personnalisation
dans ses traitements.
Donc,
c'est comme
s'il avait
pris la lettre
de l'amande
et son
ammanouance,
cette personne
qui normalement
était sous sa supervision
pour écrire les choses
et qu'il prend la lettre
et qu'il l'écrit
et de manière intentionnelle,
il fait exprès
non seulement
de faire des grandes lettres
mais de dire
qu'il est en train
de faire des grandes lettres
pour que les moments
où cette lettre
serait en train
d'être lue
à la communauté,
même ceux
qui écoutent,
qui ne voient pas
la taille des lettres,
savent
que nous sommes
devant la taille
des lettres.
Et donc,
il y a beaucoup
de personnalisations
ici qui montrent
la vraie affection
et en contraste,
on a considéré
que la Bible
nous exhorte
quand elle parle
des imposteurs,
des hypocrites religieux
à plusieurs formes
différentes
des dissimulations
d'affection
ou des mauvaises affections
ou des fausses affections.
Donc,
Matthieu 7,
c'est l'un des passages
les plus avertissants
à cet égard
où même les personnes
qui peuvent enseigner
correctement,
même opérer des miracles
par la puissance
des dieux,
Christ peut leur dire
à la fin des temps
« Je ne vous ai jamais connus
car vous pratiquez
l'iniquité ».
Et ces personnes
disent « Seigneur,
Seigneur »,
c'est que dans
la culture
hébraïque,
vous la signifiez
affection,
un phase sur les affections,
l'émotionalisme
chrétien.
Et donc,
des fois,
nous créons
dans nos environnements
religieux
une idée des dieux
qui n'est pas biblique
et des attentes
envers dieux
qui sont purement charnelles.
On est là plutôt
pour imaginer
une meilleure vie
dans les mondes
et on va transférer
envers dieux
ces attentes
et des fois,
certains faux prophètes
vont vous promener
aussi les mêmes choses
que Satan promit
à Jésus-Christ.
« Je te donnerai
à tous les mondes
si prosterné
tu m'adores ».
Et donc,
les personnes
qui vivent
des vies difficiles
en voyant
un prophète
qui promet
la prospérité terrestre
sont en train
de démontrer
beaucoup d'émotionalisme.
Gloire à Dieu,
par contre,
ni les dieux
présentés
et les dieux bibliques,
ni ceux
qui sont en train
de provoquer
leur affection
sont des raisons
légitimes.
Ils ne sont pas
émerveillés
par la gloire
de Dieu,
par la sainteté
par la beauté
de la sainteté
de Dieu.
Leur intérêt
n'est pas
la progression
du royaume
de Dieu,
mais faire
des dieux
en expenseur
de leur propre
idolâtrie charnelle.
et donc,
il y a beaucoup
de dissimulations
et beaucoup
de fausses affections
au sein de l'Église
et nous avons abordé
plusieurs d'entre elles
le dimanche dernier.
Sauf que,
il faut savoir
et connaître
que même
les affections
religieuses
peuvent être
dissimulées
et nous ne serons
pas toujours
capables
à chaque instant
de nous dire
clairement
voici une affection
qui n'est pas vraie.
Nous pouvons plutôt
à long terme
avoir une idée
plus claire
de ceux
qui sont en train
de démontrer
des réelles affections
pour nous
en ayant
une affection
évidente d'abord
pour Dieu,
son évangile
et son peuple.
Mais l'imposteur,
parfois,
il manifeste
des affections
qui nous semblent
légitimes,
mais il n'est pas
constant
et il n'est pas
proportionnel
aux circonstances.
Des fois,
on voit
des personnes
qui peuvent
dissimuler
ou même
éprouver
une mesure
émotionnelle
mais qui n'est pas
du tout proportionnelle
au mal
qu'elle est en train
de provoquer,
à la souffrance
qu'elle est en train
de causer.
Des fois,
on voit
des personnes
qui sont
apathiques
envers les choses
de Dieu
et les choses
de l'Évangile.
C'est un très mauvais
signe.
et donc,
je vous encouragerai
à revenir
pour ces questions
de l'affection
religieuse.
Et la deuxième réponse
que nous allons
considérer aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'une vie
qui se glorifie
réellement dans la croix,
elle promeut
la liberté
ou la libération
par les dons
des soi.
Elle est disposée
à se donner,
à perdre sa vie
pour que d'autres
gagnent la vie.
Mais,
les imposteurs,
ils cherchent
l'autopréservation
par la manipulation
du peuple des dieux.
Donc,
d'un côté,
quelqu'un
qui est prédisposé
à mourir
pour promouvoir
la liberté
du peuple des dieux,
et d'autres
qui,
de manière cachée,
sont en train
de chercher
leur propre
autopréservation,
qui ne vont pas
sonner toujours
comme confrontants,
mais ils sont
en train
de manipuler.
Ils sont en train
de nous rendre
esclaves.
Ils sont en train
de chercher
pas à nous affranchir,
à nous donner
de la liberté
de l'enfant des dieux,
mais nous donner
l'impression
qu'ils sont
les seuls
et les meilleurs
capables
de juger
ce qui est
profitable
ou non
dans notre vie
spirituelle.
Et c'est étonnant
de voir
jusqu'à où
ils peuvent aller
ce que nous pouvons
faire de la religion
ou ce que la religion
peut faire de nous.
Car quand on lit
les versets 12,
tous ceux qui veulent
se rendre
réagir
selon la chair
vous contraignent
à vous faire
circoncire
uniquement
afin de n'être
pas persécutés
pour la croix
de Christ.
Donc,
ils ont évité
de parler
de l'escalade
de la croix,
les choses difficiles
de la vie chrétienne
afin de sonner
agréable
devant nous
comme s'ils avaient
un réel intérêt
dans notre
état spirituel
sauf que
leur but
c'est une
autopréservation
dans ces mondes.
leur intérêt
est envers
eux-mêmes.
Et le plus grand
absurde
c'est que
dans ce contexte
cette manipulation
représente
vous faire
circoncire.
Vous imaginez
les niveaux
d'intimité
que cela peut
exiger.
Et l'aspect
irréversible
car à nouveau
même si parfois
on a une partie
des coupabilités
sous leurs
exploitations,
manipulations,
sous leur
apparence
de sainteté
et des positions
religieuses
d'autorité
ou des positions
dans un cadre
familial
avec l'impression
qu'ils savent
mieux que nous
les choses des dieux
ou la spiritualité
et qu'ils nous
conduisent
à faire des sacrifices
bêtes
qui Dieu n'a jamais
exigées de nous
afin qu'on soit
quelque part
complice
de jusqu'à où
ils sont en train
de nous amener
à point d'être
violés
dans notre conscience
d'être abusés
envers des choses
qui peuvent
sembler
irréversibles.
La circoncision
de la chair.
Donc
déjà
c'est une
autopréservation
manipulatrice.
Paul
de manière très sage
il dit
tous ceux
qui
pourquoi
il ne va pas
mentionner
les noms
exacts
des personnes
qui sont
concernées.
Déjà
pour ne pas
donner
la plateforme.
Déjà
car s'ils sont
clairement dévoilés
comme des imposteurs
ce n'est pas
le moment
de leur donner
de nouvelles
opportunités
de manipuler
les peuples
des dieux
de la
dissimulation.
Paul n'a jamais
organisé
un débat
avec les judaïsants
sur internet.
lorsqu'il est
parti
à Jérusalem
pour traiter
les problèmes
il a dit
exprès
on a vu ça
dans cette lettre
je n'ai
dépensé
un seul second
avec eux
je me dirigeais
directement
aux apôtres
de Jérusalem.
aucune
plateforme
donnée
à ces personnes.
La probabilité
ou la possibilité
de répentance
peut être légitime
sauf que
l'historique
qu'ils ont
construit
avec
leur manipulation
les niveaux
de leur dissimulation
au sein
des choses
sacrées
fait que
l'Église
soit
obligée
plutôt
à considérer
sa capacité
de dissimulation
dans les présents
comme plus dangereuse
qu'elle
se sentir
obligée
à pardonner
de manière légère.
Et donc
tous ceux
sans faire référence
à leur nom.
Mais tous ceux
aussi
pour nous inclure.
Tous ceux
qui veulent
se rendre
agréables
selon la chair
donc
circoncision
dans la chair
une possibilité
de vouloir
nous rendre
agréables
apparemment
devant Dieu
car
accompagnés
de la circoncision
de la chair
étaient tous les systèmes
d'externalité
religieuse.
Mais oui
c'est rendre agréable
selon la chair
devant vous.
Être agréable
dans cette capacité
de développer
les relations
d'avoir
les mots
douces
ou la subtilité
satanique
dont ils peuvent
même s'aimer
la diffamation
envers les vrais
ministres
les vrais apôtres
afin de nous
donner l'impression
que ce sont
eux
qui ont
du vrai
intérêt
envers nous.
Une procédure
parasitaire.
Ils n'ont pas
construit
cette relation.
Cette église
n'a pas
été les fruits
de leur travail.
Et donc
quelque part
si nous sommes
tentés
par ces personnes
par la manière
dont
en général
elle grandit
l'opportunité
de nous dissimuler
lorsqu'ils nous
motivent
par les mêmes
motivations
charnelles
qu'ils ont
lorsqu'ils
leur discours
se concentrent
sur la surface
de nos difficultés
immédiates
des possibilités
d'avantages
des positions
au sein de l'église
si on a l'impression
que par exemple
les judaïsants
avec tous les supports
qu'ils reçoivent
leur capacité
de se présenter
avec de la prospérité
tous les respects
ethniques
politiques
qu'ils ont
et qu'ils
comparent
avec la vie
d'un apôtre Paul
qui n'a même pas
où récliner sa tête
comme les Christ
qui est persécuté
à gauche
et à droite
peut-être
que l'évangile
de la prospérité
de ces faux apôtres
c'est plus intéressant
pour moi
et donc si
en nous laissant
influencer
par ces personnes
nous aussi
nous retrouvons
en cherchant
à être agréable
selon la chair
à commencer
à être très conscient
de la manière
dont on se porte
la façon
dont on parle
pour devenir
des experts
dans la création
des bonnes relations
on doit
poser la question
si nous ne
retrouvons pas
de leur côté
l'autopréservation
manipulatrice
qui commence
avec cette intentionnalité
de l'apôtre Paul
de généraliser
ses comportements
possibilités
que nous
serons retrouvés
sous cette influence
ils veulent
se rendre agréable
selon la chair
ce qui montre
quelle est la motivation
à la surface
s'est rendre agréable
c'est la volonté
de créer
une réputation
plaisante
et c'est ça
pour moi
la folie
des imposteurs
car moi
en ayant été
converti
sans avoir eu
un arrière-plan
chrétien
pour moi
c'était toujours
incompréhensible
pour moi
la procédure
imposteur
de certaines églises
juste pour donner
un exemple
j'ai sorti
d'une communauté
où j'étais
mêlé au surf
donc c'était vraiment
une jeunesse très cool
j'avais tous ceux
qui les jeunes
voulaient désirer
en étant
promiscu
perdu
etc
et lorsque je me suis converti
c'était véritablement
par une pleine conviction
de péché
et c'était clair
dans l'oeuvre de Dieu
pour sa gloire
sa grâce sur ma vie
ces changements
et là mes amis
un peu plus jeunes
qui étaient intéressés
par certaines églises
m'amenaient avec eux
à certaines églises
et que je suis rentré
l'impression c'est
qu'on était plutôt
dans une boîte de nuit
et là je me disais
dans mon coeur
mais c'est pas du tout ça
qui m'a attiré
envers Dieu
et en réalité
en fait parfois
ce sont des stratégies
pour plaire
ceux qui ne sont jamais
convertis
qui ont été élevés
dans un environnement
chrétien
et qui veulent
satisfaire
leur désir charnel
de manière indirecte
donc c'est rendre
agréable
selon la chair
pour moi
c'était une folie
car je me disais
là tout cela
Satan me donnait
beaucoup plus
et il faisait
encore mieux
mais la question
pour moi
encore plus accablante
c'est mais comment
même dans les environnements
un peu plus conservateurs
un peu plus bibliques
dans la surface
les judaïsants
les légalistes
comment une personne
qui n'ait jamais
été convertie
a l'intérêt
d'avoir des positions
d'évidence
au sein de l'église
si cette personne
veut se livrer
à ces passions charnelles
pourquoi
elle ne se livre
pas totalement
au monde
mais c'est intéressant
car parfois
c'est les seuls
environnements
qu'ils ont connus
dans lesquels
ils ont été élevés
même leur sensation
d'importance
se retrouve
dans cette identité
superficielle
et ils arrivent même
à oser
occuper des positions
d'importance
des services
à l'église
en n'ayant
aucune
expérience
réelle
avec
les choses
qu'ils ont
la capacité
de dire
et qui sont
fidèles
à l'évangile
biblique
ils peuvent
même
avoir la capacité
d'exprimer
une certaine
conscience
des moments
où ils vont
dissimuler
leur affection
mais il y a
cet intérêt
d'être agréable
devant la chair
d'avoir
une réputation
cette dissimulation
selon la chair
ne veut pas dire
tout simplement
car ils réussissent
à plaire
les personnes
autour d'eux
mais
cette dissimulation
elle est
selon la chair
ils se sont
habitués
avec
l'environnement
religieux
et c'est
selon la chair
qu'ils veulent
créer cette réputation
c'est à dire
c'est pas
enraciné
dans leur esprit
donc ici
ceux qui veulent
se rendre
réglables
selon la chair
sont ceux
qui de manière
très subtile
dissimulent
des comportements
chrétiens
avec le but
de se rendre
agréable
pas devant Dieu
mais selon la chair
devant les hommes
envers
les personnes
qui cherchent
à manipuler
ils ont besoin
de se rendre
agréable
et se rendre
comme s'ils étaient
agréables
devant Dieu
vous comprenez ça
et c'est là
où nous voyons
la vulnérabilité
de l'église
et c'est là
où nous voyons
l'aspect grave
et immoral
de cette dissimulation
car c'est au sang
du peuple
de Dieu
en pleine moquerie
contre Dieu
et en voulant
exploiter
ce qu'il y a
de plus noble
chez les chrétiens
ils occupent
à nouveau
des positions
d'influence
soit à la maison
soit à l'église
et ils exploitent
cette vulnérabilité
donc envers
les manipuler
les abuser
mais aussi
comme on verra bientôt
envers ceux
qui ont
la plus grande influence
car c'est pour
ne pas être persécutés
qu'ils sont
en train de le faire
donc il y a
un autre agenda
derrière
mais il y a aussi
du plaisir
même dans leur capacité
de dissimuler
comme certains films
qu'on voit
qui cherchent à exploiter
ces désirs charnels
même en nous
car on s'amuse
parfois
de regarder
la capacité
de dissimulation
de certains hommes
donc
en cherchant
à créer
une réputation
plaisante
il vous constreint
à vous faire circoncire
donc quelle est la méthode
utilisée par ces personnes
contrainte
insistance
c'est une espèce
d'autorité
imposée
ils deviennent
de plus en plus
agréables
pour qu'on croit
qu'ils ont
de la bonne intention
envers nous
et en même temps
ils donnent l'impression
qu'ils sont
surtout agréables
devant Dieu
par leur légalisme
par leur position
d'influence
par la sensation
qu'ils sont plus
spirituelles
que nous
et à partir
de là
ils ont
cette manière
de nous
contraindre
c'est une
contrainte
qui
devient insistante
imaginez-vous
les galates
ils connaissaient mieux
ils ont été exposés
à l'évangile
de la pôtre Paul
ils avaient
contemplé
la réalité
d'un ministre
en pleine
authenticité
dans son ministère
lorsqu'il était
entre eux
il était presque mort
sous persécution
en donnant sa vie
pour eux
donc ils avaient
eu un bon repère
des vrais
ministres
et les meilleurs
repères qu'on pourrait
imaginer
du vrai évangile
mais ces personnes
doivent donc
insister
ils doivent être
obstinés
ils doivent faire
beaucoup d'usages
des coercitions
jusqu'à ce
que nous pouvons
céder
à leur influence
et attention
et d'ailleurs
il faut qu'on soit
attentif
au discours
monothématique
même aujourd'hui
et même dans
les réseaux
les plus authentiques
qu'on connaît
des fois
nous pouvons identifier
des missionnaires
de la circoncision
parce que nous voyons
des églises
qui peuvent dire
avec nous
que nous avons
de l'unité
dans les principales
mais quand on va
s'approcher un peu plus
de leur ministère
on voit qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus intéressés
à nous convaincre
d'une position théologique
particulière
que de l'évangile lui-même
et qui font usage
de leur position
d'influence
ou d'importance
pour soutenir
parfois
tous les ressources
que leur réseau
peut investir
dans leur vie
car ils sont notamment
non en train
de promouvoir
le cœur de l'évangile
mais
certains courants
théologiques
et c'est clair
qu'ici
nous sommes devant
une évidente
dissimulation
ça me fait rappeler
un épisode
qu'on a vécu
à mon église
au Brésil
où l'un des anciens
qu'on avait
qui pour moi
était comme un ange
des lumières
vraiment
même lorsque Dieu
a manifesté clairement
un jugement sur lui
il a souffert
un accident de voiture
très grave
et il a été épargné
donc au lieu d'arriver
à l'église
en soupliant
les pardons des dieux
il a révé l'église
en disant
l'ennemi
a voulu envoiler
ma vie
même comme ça
je suis venu à l'église
pour adorer Dieu
des personnes
qu'on connait
on fait une fois
un voyage
on voyage avec lui
et pendant la nuit
une personne s'est levée
pour prendre de l'eau
et la retrouver
à genouiller
en priant
et même avec des larmes
la vérité
c'est que tout le long
cette personne
était en train de voler
l'argent de l'église
n'a jamais été converti
le niveau
de dissimulation
il est vraiment
très élevé
tous ses efforts
pour se faire
à grève
selon la chair
toute cette contente
et
à un moment donné
chez nous
il y aura toujours
cette sensation
mais
ça ne va pas trop
voilà pourquoi
ils doivent insister
car si nous connaissons
vraiment la vérité
on hésite
on n'est pas en paix
on peut même
faire des concessions
mais à un moment donné
on va se sentir
plutôt abusé
et lorsque les choses
sont dévoilées
et ça c'est l'aspect
le plus cruel
quand on va traiter
des cas pastoraux
c'est que
tous les longs
il n'y avait
aucun intérêt réel
dans notre bien-être
spirituel
on se sent
trahi
utilisé
on se sent
violé
et parfois
on se sent
esclave
des conséquences
de ces viols
de ces abus
parfois
c'est très dur
pour certains
de se laisser porter
envers
la commission
d'un péché grave
mais l'arrogance
humaine
et la sensation
des viols
parfois
font que ça soit
encore plus difficile
de nous détacher
d'une position
théologique
qu'on a changé
de l'orthodoxie
sous l'influence
des imposteurs
ou des abus
qu'on a souffert
donc dans ces cas-là
c'est la circoncision
quel niveau
d'intimité
on a dû permettre
ces hommes
d'arriver
dans nos vies
pour nous exploiter
parce que Rebecca
était née
on a six enfants
donc on était
plus ou moins
déjà habitués
aux procédures
après la naissance
il y avait
quelque chose
de nouveau
qui nous a fait
élévier
un rapport rouge
donc c'était
maintenant
une pratique
courante
d'évaluer
les francs
de la langue
et suggérer
qu'on fasse
les traitements
la mini-chirurgie
si vous voulez
qui reste quand même
assez invasive
et pour nous
même si
pour certains enfants
c'est clair
que c'est nécessaire
ça ne nous a pas sonné
comme c'était
les caporels
et c'était pas
la pratique habituelle
avant sa naissance
donc on a appris
on a fait
une recherche
on a appris
qu'il y a
tout un mouvement
dans sa direction
pour récent
et une opposition
grande possibilité
aux probabilités
donc je ne veux pas
rentrer dans les détails
car je n'ai pas
toutes les informations
mais la réalité
c'est que ceux
qui connaissent
les systèmes médicaux
savent que parfois
certains médecins
peuvent même
arriver à suggérer
des chirurgies
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas
nécessaires
et donc si nous
en tant que parents
on s'est senti un peu
violés
abusés
par les systèmes
car après on a consulté
d'autres
qui ont dit
qu'on n'avait pas besoin
imaginez-vous
ceux qui se sont fait
circoncis
imaginez-vous
par exemple
les sacrifices
qu'on doit faire
la trahison pratiquée
contre l'apôtre Paul
contre ceux
qui l'aiment le plus
parfois leurs propres parents
donc ceux qui veulent
vous contraignent
à vous faire circoncire
donc là malheureusement
il faut savoir reconnaître
dans plusieurs cas
nous sommes devant
qu'elles sont victimes
c'est évident
surtout quand ces hommes
sont en train d'exploiter
les bébés
les enfants
les petits-enfants
et notamment
spirituels
par contre
ce n'était pas
le cas pour cette église
et donc
ils sont en train
de vous contraindre
mais c'est vous
qui devez prendre
la décision
c'est vous
qui devez vous faire
circoncire
et donc ici
Paul va révéler
leur motivation
suprême
uniquement
afin de n'être
pas persécutés
pour la croix
du Christ
donc là
la motivation
dans la surface
c'est la réputation
les plaisirs
d'une bonne réputation
par contre
la motivation
réelle
c'est l'autopréservation
à chaque instant
un comportement
calculé
envers vous
pour qu'il ne soit pas
découvert
calculé devant vous
pour que
leur vie
leur prospérité
leur position
charanelle
c'est comme
ces pasteurs libéraux
dans sa théologie
disaient
à mon pasteur
au Brésil
devant
l'académie
j'ai dit
ce que je pense
la parole de Dieu
n'est pas
elle contient
la parole de Dieu
par contre
à l'église
car dès là
vient mon soutien
mon salaire
j'ai fait semblant
que je suis orthodoxe
il y en a beaucoup
et donc
la réalité
c'est que
l'intérêt
de ces personnes
il est politique
n'est pas
être persécuté
donc la motivation
ultime
unique
pragmatique
c'était
l'autopréservation
charnelle
la préservation
de leur position
leur rang
et donc
uniquement
en même intérêt
même pas d'intérêt
dans la circoncision
à elle-même
il ne croyait
même pas
à ce qu'il prêchait
et encore moins
de l'intérêt
envers vous
et votre bien
c'était purement
une relation utilitaire
d'exploitation
en faisant
osage
du peuple
des dieux
pour plaire
les personnes
qui tenaient
la puissance
et les pouvoirs
politiques
donc les calculs
de saisir
à chaque fois
et de lire
la vie
par
la politique
donc
cette influence
religieuse
juive
pour qu'il vous rappelez
bien
la persécution
primaire
de l'église
c'était la persécution
des juifs
Christ a été crucifié
à cause de ça
ok
et donc
quand même
l'église a beaucoup
grandi
elle avait
à temps
avec
explosion
même à l'extérieur
les mondes anciens
à plusieurs égales
voici
une bonne opportunité
politique
nous y allons
et nous allons
collectionner
des prépuces
pour revenir
à Jérusalem
et dire
regarde
comment nous avons
la capacité
d'unifier
les judaïsaires
il n'y a qu'un seul
judaïsme
et nous pouvons
faire du christianisme
un affluent
un courant
judaïque
il n'y a qu'un seul
christianisme
nous allons faire
des efforts
aujourd'hui
pour l'écoménisme
nous allons chercher
à rassembler
sous
les parapluies
dans tel réseau
évangélique
toutes les versions
de la chrétienté
uniquement pour ne pas
être persécutées
donc leur vrai désir
c'était similaire
au désir politique
qui nous voit
aujourd'hui
car ils voulaient
tirer de l'avantage
de toutes les religions
toutes les dénominations
affluentes
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui
même certains politiques
lorsqu'ils voient
la croissance
des évangéliques
ils veulent parfois
avoir un espace
honoré au sein de ces églises
et certaines églises
les font
on voulait aujourd'hui
remercier la présence
on n'est pas chez nous
on est dans la maison
des dieux
il faut avoir
l'espoir pour tous
pour Matthieu
les publicans
Simon les élotes
c'est intéressant
de voir
dans cette manière
de vouloir
créer
une unité
artificielle
externe
politique
ou pragmatique
ils étaient les missionnaires
de la bonne entendance
ils cherchaient
à atténuer
ce qui est
moralement
inatténuable
qu'est-ce qu'ils voulaient faire
ils voulaient
prêcher
l'évangile
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
sans sa croix
ils cherchaient
à atténuer
les scandales
de la croix
et ça
pourrait être
une tentation
pour les pasteurs
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
car
si on était
en train de parler
de la rhétorique
humaine
comme l'apôtre Paul
l'a dit
j'ai décidé
de rien savoir
entre vous
à part Christ
et celui-ci crucifié
folie pour les grecs
scandale pour les juifs
comment
les messies promis
qui dans la mentalité
juive
du premier siècle
était la mentalité
d'un messie
politique
militaire
terrestre
comment
pourrait-il finir
à la croix
les lieux
des malédictions
des mauditions
scandale pour les juifs
mais scandale
pour tous ceux
qui sont exposés
à la croix
car les messages
de la croix
c'est
voici
ce qui vous méritez
ce qui
tous vos efforts
est d'abord
un message
pour les juifs
malgré
votre circoncision
et malgré
vos lourdes
rituels religieux
et votre apparence
de sainteté
et votre transpiration
pour plaire Dieu
voici
ce qui vous méritez
voici les vrais rois
des juifs
c'est vous
qui devriez
être là
et plutôt
à l'enfer
car Christ a vécu
cet enfer
condensé à la croix
et donc la croix
c'est les lieux
majeurs
d'exposition
de notre
misère spirituelle
ces messages
sera toujours
en scandale
pour n'importe
quel être humain
car tous les êtres humains
sont orgueilleux
ils veulent toujours
participer
à leur salut
à leur rédemption
la croix
sans son scandale
n'est pas la croix
mais particulièrement
dans ce contexte
elle devenait
la persécution
automatique
de la part
des plus influents
donc pour tous ceux
qui voulaient suggérer
que les Christ
crucifiés
étaient les Messies
les Messies crucifiés
persécution
et quel était
l'élan
des judaïsants
c'était à contre-courant
de la croix
de l'évangile
c'était un évangile
sans croix
un évangile
sans souffrance
et particulièrement
un évangile
sans souffrance
volontaire
sans la conscience
que les rois des rois
les juges des juges
vont retourner un jour
mais
entre temps
notre mission
c'est de promouvoir
l'évangile
tout comme Christ
en nous portant
et nous chargeant
de notre croix
en nous laissant mourir
pour promouvoir la vie
et donc
ils étaient en train
d'atténuer
l'inatténuable
c'est-à-dire
la croix
Dieu
dans son descend
il a voulu
intentionnellement
accrocher
son message
des bonnes nouvelles
à la croix
à l'escendal
de la croix
car il n'y a pas
d'histoire
pour la conversion
d'aucune personne
et il n'y a pas
de changement
dans la nature
de l'oeuvre du Christ
par contre
ces hommes
ils étaient en train
d'atténuer
l'immoralité
commise
par les juifs
lorsqu'ils ont crucifié
les fils de Dieu
vous comprenez
donc à chaque fois
qu'on essaie
de nous associer
avec une version
du christianisme
qui est plutôt
en train de chercher
à atténuer
les scandales
de la croix
nous sommes en train
de commettre
les mêmes péchés
des judaïsants
mais plus que ça
ils étaient en train
d'atténuer aussi
la réalité
de la persécution
du déversement
de sang
qui était en train
d'avoir lieu
envers nos frères
et sœurs
chrétiens
donc lorsqu'on va
faire un débat
avec les catholiques
ou lorsqu'on va
suggérer
que nous pouvons
avoir de la communion
avec eux
nous sommes en train
de diminuer
l'importance
de tous les sangs
versés
que nos frères
et sœurs
ont vécu
dans le passé
atténuer
l'inatténuable
concilier
l'irréconciliable
un légalisme
par lequel
par nos efforts
on va chercher
à plaire Dieu
par la circoncision
contrairement
à l'évangile
de la grâce
seule
par la foi
en Jésus seul
chercher à concilier
la circoncision
de la chair
avec la vraie circoncision
historique
et spirituelle
Christ crucifié
car la circoncision
avait pour but
de communiquer
les besoins
qui en descendant
arrivent
en descendant d'Abraham
afin qu'il se charge
de la vraie expiation
nous avions besoin
d'une expiation
qui soit radicalement
séminale
depuis la source
de l'humanité
et Christ
est cette sémence
qui arrive
et lui-même
est extirpé
de la terre
des vivants
c'est lui
la vraie
circoncision
la circoncision
effective
c'est lui
qui déverse
les sang
pour extirper
la coupabilité
et la pollution
du péché
donc c'est impossible
de chercher
à concilier
l'obsolète
la circoncision
de l'ancienne alliance
avec la vraie
circoncision
en Jésus Christ
la circoncision
spirituelle
c'est de chercher
à concilier
les saints esprits
avec
son rôle
de nous apporter
l'expérience
et la filiation
universelle
de tous les peuples
et de réduire
à nouveau cela
au rôle didatique
d'Israël
ethnique
sous l'administration
de la loi
la filiation ethnique
et charnelle
comme si
les termes
de l'histoire
étaient jusqu'aujourd'hui
Israël
et pas l'Église
et c'est de chercher
donc
à atténuer
l'inatténuable
concilier
l'irréconcilable
séparer
l'inséparable
l'évangile
de l'escanal
de la croix
c'est impossible
vous avez l'idée
que lorsque
nous portons
parfois
la croix
c'est comme
si on était
en train
de porter
une chaise électrique
ou la guillotine
vous pouvez imaginer
l'impact
de ça
dans la société
de l'époque
et nous
sommes en train
de dire
voici
ce qui parle
qui je suis
je suis celui
qui devrait
être
maudit
et extirpé
de la terre
des vivants
de la manière
la plus appropriée
à ma réputation
véritable
misérable
homme
que je suis
et lui
il a vécu ça
à ma place
ce qui fait
un contraste
qu'il est
le vrai ministre
au lieu de vivre
cette réalité
d'imposteur
au lieu de
par exploitation
enlever la liberté
pour manipuler
pour l'autopréservation
on voit que dans la vie
d'un homme
des dieux
c'est le complet
opposé
il n'est pas
préoccupé
à se rendre
agréable
selon la chair
car
en ayant
eu l'expérience
réelle des conversions
il sait
qu'à la croix
du Christ
il n'a plus rien
à préserver
il n'a aucun
intérêt
à suggérer
une réputation
qu'il sait
que c'est impossible
d'avoir
car sa réputation
c'est
chaise électrique
c'est croix
du Christ
c'est enfer
et désormais
il n'a que la réputation
de vrai Christ
à promouvoir
la réputation
de Christ
en moi
il a tout
gagné à la croix
lorsqu'il a tout
perdu à la croix
donc
sa seule préoccupation
c'est de se rendre
agréable
devant Dieu
et pas devant les hommes
il sait
qu'il est déjà
attention
il a déjà
tout perdu
il a été déjà
mort
à l'enfer
c'est ça la vérité
pour tous les vrais
chrétiens
si la pire des morts
on a déjà vécu
en Christ
à la croix
on peut
ne pas
craindre la mort
aujourd'hui
et voilà pourquoi
il est en train
l'apôtre Paul
par les dons
de soi
risqué
de mourir
et il va mourir
sous persécution
quand il était déjà
mort
pour soi-même
il veut
qu'il seulement
être grave
selon
Dieu
selon l'esprit
et passer
dans la chair
il peut faire
des exhortations
franches
sans craindre
que les personnes
vont délaisser
l'assemblée
il ne va pas
adapter
les messages
au goût du client
car il veut
plaire
l'audience
d'une seule personne
Dieu lui-même
et il sait
que les vrais
vont rester
vont revenir
il les aînés
pour les biens
réels
des sangs
donc il promeut
la vraie liberté
par les moyens
de la vérité
avec amour
et non par contrainte
un pasteur
véritable
vous affranchit
il vous donne
la conne à pêche
au lieu de
vous suggérer
qu'il a besoin
d'être toujours là
afin de vous nourrir
il fait confiance
à l'oeuvre
du Saint-Esprit
dans vos vies
donc par le moyen
de la vérité
avec l'amour
on n'a pas l'impression
qu'ils sont là
en train de nous contraindre
à faire les choses
et ils sont surtout
en train de stimuler
la conviction
que l'efficacité
de l'influence
du Saint-Esprit
de la filiation
est infiniment
plus puissante
pour vous sanctifier
que les menaces
de perdre
votre filiation
perdre votre salut
ils sont assurés
de la sanctification
progressive
des vrais enfants
de Dieu
car c'est là
où nous retrouvons
chez les vrais chrétiens
la conviction
qu'ils sont
des enfants de Dieu
par la manière
dont ils vivent
par leur affection
pour Dieu
pour Christ
pour les ciels
et donc
ils les font
parler dans des soirs
c'est la preuve majeure
d'intérêt réel
dans la vie
du peuple de Dieu
si vous voulez
être sûr
que vous êtes
devant un ministre
ou un chrétien
légitime
cherchez
à considérer
combien
de sacrifices
ils sont en train
de faire
combien
ils sont en train
de veillir
plus tôt
pour les biens
de ses frères et soeurs
combien
de sacrifices
ils sont en train
de faire
comme l'apôtre Paul
était ses modèles
comme Christ lui-même
car là
c'est les modèles
si j'ai mes glories
qu'à la croix du Christ
j'ai mes glories
sur cette rédemption
historique
mais j'ai mes glories
aussi sur ses motifs
sur ses paramètres
sur cette manière
de vivre
en dépit
de la persécution
ou des possibles
avantages politiques
et là
il faut juste
conclure
avec une nuance
on sait très bien
que certains chrétiens
seront appelés
à la vocation politique
et c'est clair
que nous avons besoin
de ça
il faut prier
c'est peut-être
l'un des emplois
ou l'un des métiers
les plus délicats
pour un chrétien
d'exercer
pour une personne
mêlée à la politique
certaines coopérations
peuvent être légitimes
par contre
il est
avant tout
un chrétien
son allégeance ultime
est à Dieu
il ne peut pas négocier
la vérité
à cet égard
et parfois
Dieu donne
à certains prédicateurs
certains pasteurs
certains ministres
une influence
importante
même envers
la politique
c'est les cas
pour Jean Calvin
et pour plusieurs d'autres
quand on considère
les cas
de Jean Baptiste
c'est très intéressant
car même si son influence
arrive jusqu'à Hérode
son insistance
à ne pas négocier
la vérité
va faire qu'Hérode
cherche
à supprimer
sa conscience
en exécutant
cette conscience
à l'extérieur
qui était Jean Baptiste
l'apôtre Paul
il a vécu
la même chose
quand on regarde
l'histoire de l'église
on a vu
que les vrais hommes
de Dieu
n'ont jamais
cherché
à atténuer
l'inatténuable
à séparer
ce qui est inséparable
ils n'étaient pas
préoccupés
à jouer
avec la politique
l'histoire
de la réforme
en France
elle est très puissante
on commence
avec un groupe
des mots
où tous étaient
des bases catholiques
et qui commencent
à mettre en question
les systèmes catholiques
à un moment donné
même la soeur
du roi
François 1er
Marguerite
de Navarre
va sponsoriser
les mouvements
des origines
évangéliques
ou protestantes
mais à un moment donné
après
certains échanges
notamment après
les colloques
des Poissy
ils arrivent à la conclusion
que les débats
ne vont amener
à rien
car l'intérêt catholique
était plutôt
de faire des évangéliques
une vertente
une afflouante
un courant
sous la domination
et sous les contrôles
politiques des catholiques
depuis ce moment
qu'Alguyen a compris
il y a cette claire rupture
et le long de l'histoire
c'est la même chose
quand on arrive
dans cette scission
entre les puritans
dissidents
et les anglicans
et les conformistes
on voit la même chose
ils disent
que c'était
la connexion
de ces puritans
à l'influence
des Calvin à Genève
qui l'ont fait comprendre
qui par la politique
ils n'arrivaient pas
à chercher
à négocier
un milieu-chement
entre les judaïsants catholiques
et la vraie foi
chrétienne
plus récemment
on a vu les efforts
de Lloyd-Jones
à Sisplome
à Carthur
de s'opposer
à ces mouvements
entre les catholiques
et évangéliques
ensemble
et malheureusement
il faut qu'aujourd'hui
on soit
dans nos gardes
contre ces influences
le plus important
pour nous
c'est de nous retrouver
du côté
de ceux qui
cherchent à promouvoir
la vraie liberté
par les dons de soi
une vie qui se glorifie
réellement
dans la croix
promeut
la liberté
par les dons de soi
plutôt que
l'autopréservation
manipulatrice